Manchester City are champions of England
Liverpool took it to the final game on
the final day but Manchester City held
their nerve to win back-to-back Premier
League titles and lift that trophy in
the next few minutes
[Applause]
his fantastic choirs the scenes at full
time after man said he dispatched
Brighton with relative ease for one
despite initially going behind at the
AMEX stadium unsurprisingly
it was a much more somber mood in
Liverpool where their to nil win against
wolves ultimately made no difference to
the title race well Nick Powell is here
he's our sports editor Nick what a
season what a week I mean it did look a
bit dodgy at the beginning there at
Brighton though it did and I think it
was it was kind of fitting that after a
season like this and a week latticed
where we've seen Liverpool and Tottenham
pull off extraordinary comebacks in New
York that there was drama the lead did
change and again on the final day and
those Manchester City fans who are very
happy now and very relaxed now in the
sunshine on the south coast were
extremely nervous as Liverpool took the
lead early on against wolves and they're
particularly so when 483 seconds that's
all
Brighton were actually ahead against
Manchester City I thought is it going to
be
Liverpool's day is their name on the
trophy where they're going to be
champions for the first time in 29 years
it's been a long long wait there are
lots of Liverpool fans he would rather
be Premier League champions damn
champions of Europe because it's been
such a long wait but mansion City in my
opinion deservedly had been the best
team this season are the champions
Liverpool more points than any other
runner-up in history 97 points
Manchester City two points less than
last season but mosula and his Liverpool
teammates have made it a fantastic race
for the title he ends up by the way
along with his teammates a dear man who
scored twice today as the Premier
League's joint top scorer along with
Pierre Emerick aubameyang of Arsenal and
Sergio agüero just one behind the
mansion City after he scored a really
important first goal for Manchester City
and lots of scenes like this at the end
of the season as the players families
join them on the pitch there be lots and
lots of that they're all going to score
no one's going to stop the most sellers
daughter was involved last year you
might recall the very end of the season
and he has his
of the Golden Boot with 22 goals and a
very happy girl she doesn't mind that
Liverpool haven't actually won the title
they have done some amazing things this
season they've only lost one games
extraordinary the only is one game all
season and you're not champions
mentioned you've lost for Liverpool have
drawn a bit too many and to say I think
most people feel that City have the
stronger team and certainly the stronger
squad there's not much in it but
Manchester City as we now await the
presentation of the trophies they are
the champions once again for the sixth
time in their history and the second
successive time